So, Pratapur and Anandapur were built by the Pratamala, the king Pratamala.
And he was like the king, who is a tantric king, and he want to make some, these two
buildings, Pratapur and Anandapur.
But for what purpose did he want to make it?
He want to build for the protection of his power, to show his thing, yeah.
Because something he want to build, we are giving his name, as Pratapur and Anandapur.
Because he was the king, to show his power.
And his legacy, he show his legacy, so he build that one.
And that time, like this two Sikharasaili, the Sikhara style, is because he is second
wife Anandapur from India, so he was very much fond about that place.
And here, in India, he saw this Sikhara Saili, so he brought that type of style up here,
and he build this one.
And so, when he build, it was objected by the people, other people, don't build it.
What people?
Community people.
Meaning who exactly?
Who is the community?
Priest, Buddhacharya people, and other people too.
And it was objected, don't build it, don't make it, don't make it.
Because it is, like there is a stupa here.
And Anandapur is a little bit back than the hill, because it is built in, after the people,
if you dig inside, it is like a different, like a brick wall is there, wall, and other
mud.
Like, so it is extension, this hill, extension of hill.
So the people doesn't want to do like that, and people, community people doesn't want
to do it.
But what he done, after hearing that, he just make a, like, close this stupa.
Nobody was allowed to come up and do a praying up in the spring, for the six months.
And lastly, like the people said, okay, build it.
Now build it, because it is your power, if you feel like that, then build it.
So after that, it was built.
This is a story from the Rajbhok Mala, there is one book for that.
So you were saying about the height?
It is believed that this height, and the Swembu height was used to be the same, and same.
So it was a problem.
That's why after, some years after, when the Swembu was renovated, the Swembu's height
was little bit, make a little bit bigger than that, the Sikharasweti, that building.
And you said that the reason that these keep falling in the earth?
From people, we believe, from my concept, that because of like, everybody was opposing
about this, don't build it, don't build it.
But he just saw his legacy.
So that's why now also, many times it's been broken.
Not only three times, we just only knew three times, but if you see old picture, drawing
of the Swembu, always this pot-up bull is always with bamboo scarf, means something
happened in that, and so they are making of that.
So always something is happening in that place.